so the longest chapter of the whole
bible talk about god's word
and god's ten commandments god's law the
shoulders about praising god hmm what
are you talking about all right what's
in the middle
jesus you're
i hope you guys enjoyed this because i
was so
excited
[Music]
welcome to led live in crazy time like
this can we have absolute trust in god
find out on this episode of led live
[Music]
light exposing darkness so i decided to
you know share with you guys this topic
the you know the couple years that we
were living in this world i mean you
hear the news
and it and it's crazy i mean you know
people dying you know pandemic and like
down the cities
your freedoms riots and
words or i mean you name it fires fires
yeah my house right yeah and and it is
it is very crazy and and i and i believe
and i'm sure you guys believe too that
uh
to help us out in these crazy times i
mean it's just trusting god amen you
know the word of god right
and uh i just want to ask you some
questions and and the end is gonna be i
believe the message uh
we can have trust in god
so let's let's hang out and i hope you
guys watching this show is gonna be a
huge blessing in your life and and let's
check it out right and
okay so the question is
why do we have 365 days
in a year
i mean have you guys asked this question
before or just like oh yeah i remember
when i was in elementary school
so it it deals with how the planets
revolve around the sun
how the planets
around the sound yeah
yeah i mean from what i understand about
why we have it it's
uh earth revolves makes a full
revolution around the sun is 365
approximately days yeah that's that
quarter yeah that's yeah i think quarter
so that's true it's because it takes 365
days
the earth
go around the sun that's what we have it
and uh
we can see a little video here but
another question i have is why do we why
do we have
24 hours in one day
because that's one full revolution of
the earth
that's right so the earth has their own
rotation right i mean it's
it takes 24 hours
his own rotation the earth
another question why do we have seven
days and one week why not 28
why not 10 and what not five because
that's the week that god set up in
creation yeah
that's pretty interesting yeah there's
no scientific or astronomical
explanation for the seven day weekly
cycle and and i've heard that communist
countries have actually tried to add to
that calendar and it just never works
out they always have to go back to seven
we did it yeah the french revolution um
right after
that you know they implemented a 10-day
week
hey we can get nine days of work out of
these people and and isn't it if you
have an exact number of days in the
month doesn't that work out to be like
or 13 exact months
i remember what it is like like if
they're all 28 days instead of 28 29 30
31 or whatever like this it looks like
what you're talking about
but it reminds me of the way the jews
had it set up because they had a 300
uh 360 300 day calendar it was like a
perfect cycle
because i think it was like 3 6 60
degrees and then
every so many years they like added a
13th month to compensate mm-hmm
because you know they knew it was like a
short month it was awesome
but it was but it was perfect months
meaning there wasn't like like 30 days
yeah there wasn't random days up or down
up or down see i would rather prefer
that i can never remember when they're
like 30 31.
and i think it throws off your calendar
in your mind
i think god instilled inside of us a
rhythmic
um you know rhythm of life i mean i
think that's why there's the moon cycle
that's why there's a woman's cycle
that's why there's these these things
that are very commonly that come around
again and again yeah there's a man cycle
for sure especially today's world man
there's some tv showing talked about the
man cycle we need to make a show about
that too yeah
people have periods yes
so that it's kind of interesting because
i asked those questions
with you know
friends people i used to work and stuff
like that and you know people that don't
believe in god you know i asked those
questions like why do we have 365 days
and they i mean they answered them they
know boom you know i know because you
know does the earth take around the sun
and all the stuff i mean why do we have
24 hours i mean because of that and when
i asked a question
why do we have seven days a week and
they were like this
yeah
i don't know yeah yeah yeah why not 30
days in the week that's right no we're
not 10 days we're not five right yeah
but the awesome thing that
the or god right
i mean what the bible said right about
this and we found in genesis chapter two
verse two and three and i say a god
bless the seventh day and sanctified it
because that in it he had rested from
all his work which god created i mean
how awesome is that and the beginning of
creation and the beginning of of the
bible i mean that's why we have seven
days you know seven days and one week
because god created in sixth day the
whole world in the seventh day he said
you know what let's go rest he blessed
it
he also he sanctified it and i believe
the word sanctification and the word
holy
set apart you know what's kind of cool
is it's like you you've got six days
where god like condones the work right
so we're supposed to work in fact i'm
happy it's working i i work in front of
a computer most of the time
and um it started getting warm this last
week right so i bust out the rototiller
man i'm out there in the dirt like
rototilling i did it for eight hours and
i was like
this was enjoyable to me but i think
like it's really neat that god takes
this one day and he and he like ends his
creation and he says i just want you to
enjoy that
i just want you to like like like
observe the things that were made for
you and and have fun and you know the
things that i like to do on the sabbath
is spend time with my family go on
nature walks i mean those things like
reset my mind
and it's funny that people fight against
that so much you know what i mean it's
like you get this one day where it's
like you don't got to worry about all
this other
bills
you just get the opportunity to take
time spend time with your family i don't
know that people fight against the
concept of that so much because if you
think about it
we would probably do it somewhat
naturally
you know
you get burnt out if you just
do nothing
right and so you you naturally try to
take a break i mean just in society in
general
you know it's like why do we have
vacations
exactly what's the point in having a
vacation well because you know in that
work cycle you're like man i just take
some time off
so i don't know that people are
resistant to the idea of taking time off
it's just
being told
what day
they should do that right which is human
nature we don't like to be told to do
anything right that's true
interesting so the big question right i
mean can we trust in god
and i'm sure if i ask you guys
what's going to be your answer
yeah absolutely yeah absolutely uh
another question how many books has the
bible
66 66 that's correct can you name them
all
genesis exodus leviticus numbers
deuteronomy
joshua judges ruth
first and second samuel first and second
kings first and second chronicles ezra
nehemiah esther and job
songs and proverbs ecclesiastes song of
solomon and then it gets fuzzy from here
i can kind of like do it my kids do it
all the time but um i think it's a good
skill to have we talked about jeremiah
there you go isaiah jeremiah ezekiel
lamentations
joel and amos obadiah jonah micah oh no
habakkuk
oh i don't know i don't know yeah i
don't remember the order right there we
always talk about how uh music makes you
memorize stuff and i was like
alphabet you know we talked about the
alphabet being one but it's like there's
nothing even musical really about it a b
c d e m g h
i mean i guess there's some kind of
rhyme to it when you get to g and p and
all that
but like the books of the bible like i'm
always hearing people do that i'm like
this doesn't rhyme or anything how does
it work but yeah the tune's not logical
either it doesn't seem and and the new
testament one there's there's one that
my son always likes to sing and it's
like it starts out saying um this guy
had a had a had a son and he named him
this really long name and this was what
the name is matthew mark
like one continuous name and i was like
that doesn't make much sense at all my
kids have a pretty good one that's it's
very musical and makes a lot of sense
and has really good flow so that's cool
they've got it down
that's great so we have how many books
on the old testament do you guys know
um we had six like this game yeah that's
a good that's a good one if i had to
guess
i think there's 48
no no 50 less 36. i don't know what do
you have another 66.
i don't know 35. one less than 40. oh 39
39 that's right 39. what about how many
books in the new in the new testament
well if you just do math right there
no wait 66 and um 27. yeah 27 that's
right so 39 books noticed i mean 27
and the new testament
how many chapters does the bible have oh
wow yeah that's a show it's a pop quiz
bigger oh
yeah we need to find a bigger question
because the whole the whole thing about
this topic
is
can we trust god and let me tell you and
the word of god and right there in the
center of the bible we're going to find
out that god has a message for each of
us amen for the whole nation and i'm
going to share that with you guys
that's the whole thing i like that's a
whole little question so
uh how many how many chapters so if i
were to guess there's got to be at least
10 chapters
give or take in in every single book so
that would be in the tune of 600 so i'm
going to guess 500 chapters in the whole
bible 500
500 alex
yeah i'll take i'll take how many
chapters are in the bible for 500 please
keith what do you think
i don't remember what i want to say it
was it seemed like it was somewhere in
the vicinity of like 1800
i'm gonna take an average i'm gonna say
720. psalms is a hundred yeah exactly
i'm i'm not accounting jeremiah's 52
isaiah's 66 genesis is 50.
exodus is so there's some big numbers oh
in the whole bible yeah the whole book
oh
i mean it doesn't change my answer i
just i thought we were talking about
just like the new testament or something
okay so the answer is
chapters
that's where i got to 1800.
changing that so
it's almost 1200. yeah almost 12 to 100.
so
1189 chapters okay
so check this out so which chapter is
in the center of the bible
yeah there's an easy way to remember
that
i just know that if you open your bible
straight to the middle you'll probably
be in psalms or probably psalm 118 is in
the middle and if you look psalm 117 is
the shortest chapter in the bible that's
what we're going to do psalm 119 is the
longest chapter in the bible some 118 is
right in the middle that's right he is
correct
uh yeah it's uh psalms 118.
and interesting because
before that
you have
594 chapters before
that and then uh
118 i'm psalms
after that you got
594.
so 594 594 and the middle is psalms 118.
that's correct
yep that's pretty cool that's cool
so psalms
118. but let me tell you just like
kid he was saying that if you go one
chapter before 119 117 that's the
shortest chapter of the whole bible and
you go one one chapter further as 119
and that's the longest chapter of the
bible wow do you guys know what
psalms 17 the shortest chapter of the
bible it talks about
jesus whip
that's a verse psalms 117 the chapter
the the shortest chapter of the bible
praise yeah about what praise praise
praising god
amen right so
you have the center of the bible
118 the shoulder talks about praising
god
the longest is 119
what do you think it talks about
talks about a lot of stuff our need for
him um psalm 119 is the same chapter
where it has
you know
105 where it says
that god's word is a
a lamp into our feet a light unto our
path
it's the same one let's see in that one
it's like some 119 11 is a popular verse
um
what is it i gotta think here psalm one
time it has something to do with the law
of god i think by word if i hid in my
heart that i might not see that's what
it is yeah
so keeping god's word in our heart using
god's word to guide us
that's at least two themes and then
psalm 119 165
is it
165 says great peace have they that love
thy law and nothing shall offend them
i think that's what it is you should
check me 65 is it 65 or 165 maybe it's
160 is it if there if there's that many
so there's one 65 great peace have uh
have they which love thy law and nothing
shall offend so that's about again
trusting
is about god's god's law god's word so
there's a lot of god's word god's law in
psalm 119 if i remember right that's
correct so the longest chapter the whole
bible
psalms 119 talks about
trusting god
and god's word
and his holy law
so you have
the longest talk about god's word
and god's 10 commandments god's law the
shoulders about praising god hmm why are
you talking about all right what's in
the middle you're killing us jesus
you're building up you're building up
that's right that's right we're building
up guys it's gotta be about jesus i hope
you guys enjoyed this because i was so
excited 110
verse 8
okay look that's the middle that's the
message of god to the humanity
it is better to trust the lord than to
put confidence in man amen there you go
amen that's the center
of god's word that's the topic the topic
wow
so i just i just wanted to share with
you guys take when i saw that it's like
it's better to trust in the lore
to put your trust in men yeah and how
the world is doing since we trust men
and and i like how you know the
different
major people in the bible that kind of
deal with this just trusting in god at
all expense
job you know you just think like you may
not understand what's happening to you
at that time like like he's just like
literally in pain lost everything i can
only imagine what that actually
psychologically does to you
and he's just like look you made
everything you could give it to me and
you can take it away and i'm gonna trust
you in that and i think that's just
beautiful to to have that implicit trust
in him and to just know because i think
in the garden of eden eve we lost that
trust in god by him saying
this you should not do this you you can
do and all of a sudden we just went
whatever i'm going to do it and that's
what the bible says in proverbs 3 5 and
6 it says trust in the lord with all
your heart and lean not in your own
understanding and all your ways
acknowledge him and he will direct your
paths that's right all right
yeah great first illustrate
abraham is who i was thinking about when
you were talking about that you know
god what sacrificed my only son that you
you know
i didn't how did we even get the sun was
a miracle you know we were old and now
you're telling me to sacrifice him but
he knew
if god asked me to do it he's got a plan
this could be the messiah he could raise
him up whatever you know and he was
about to do it yep and it was also a
testimony of what kind of god is god
because
child sacrifice was a common
element in the time that he lived
so when god asked him to do that the
immediate thought that abraham comes to
because he's coming out earth chaldees
which is like
babylon essentially
and he's like oh are you like those
other gods because they require that we
sacrifice our children
and then he's got to go through that
whole reasoning and trust process like
you know
but you asked me to do this and you
promised me this
so like you were saying yeah can you do
this i mean if you think about it from
that angle like literally god asking you
to do something that is very common for
another civilization or another whatever
is gonna make you question am i
following the right god i mean if god
literally came to you today and said i
want you to marry a prostitute wouldn't
you be like am i on the wrong path here
like what's up but but yeah there are
times that god has asked very
interesting and strange things and for
us to just say look i may not understand
this but i'm gonna i'm gonna do what
you're asking me anyway
that's some serious trust
serious stress that's right and
like i i i want to ask you guys
kind of personal if you guys want to
share it that's great if not i mean that
was fine but what was the moment
of your life
that it was crazy
that you knew the only god
you can trust only god and god's gonna
deliver you
you guys want to share sure i got a good
one for this
so when i when i came back into the
faith because i grew up um in
christianity i grew up reading my bible
i grew up like having a actually pretty
connected relationship with with god in
in a certain way i didn't i didn't have
the heart transformation but anyway i
left that and went out into the world
and i can remember when i came back in i
mean i had dated a bunch of women that
were just like terrible and things could
have just gone totally wrong and i was
finally done with it and i was like i
don't want to date ever again like i'm
done with this and i've said i want you
lord i want to fall in love with you and
i said i'll give you my heart and i'll
do all this and it was when i did that
that he introduced me to my wife
and and it was like that's what i was
trying to find the whole time and i and
i literally made the wrong mistake raw
mistake wrong mistake and it was only
after i said okay i don't want to make
this choice anymore i just want to be in
love with you god and it was like he
gave me the desires of my heart
and so for me like i found that wow you
can actually trust god and then look
look at this
i can still remember i used to live in
hollywood and so like i would go running
up this place called runyon canyon in
hollywood and it was like you could you
could kind of see the hollywood sign and
it was up in the mountains and stuff and
when i gave my heart back to god i
remember still going up on the top of
that mountain and i used to like to look
at that mountain and look out over los
angeles and be like i'm going to take
this city right
and i was sitting there going you know
what god
i don't want this anymore
i want whatever you want me to give me
and i said i want in this war
help me get into this war like i don't
know what i'm going to do i don't know
how i'm going to be i'm not a pastor
preacher nothing but i want to serve you
god and dude he all of a sudden answered
that big time and was like here here's
the ministry here here's this do that so
i learned over the years that that man
when you put your trust in god he not
only gives you things that will make you
happy but he also shields you from
getting involved in things that will
destroy your life and that's what would
have happened to me
[Music]
yeah i got a very similar story
i mean i was in the same spot too like
the relationships when i was just like
i'm done with this you know single
forever whatever
and then god introduced me to my wife at
a point where
there were times in the past where um
you rushed the relationship and it just
like crashed and burned like three
months later it's over
and there's like it's just like it's
built on infatuation and it's just too
fast well that happened a lot but at
this point in my time in my life
i was like
i was like emotionally unavailable and
it was a good thing because it caused me
and my wife to be able to
get to know each other better without
rushing things
and and yeah god did give me my wife the
same way and then like you were saying
about the desires of your heart i
thought i wanted to
be a rock star a rapper and live in
hollywood and do all these things and
and make a clothing line t-shirts make
music videos
and
you know make music stuff like that
and then when i've got to that surrender
moment because god was like look you're
right here you can if you pursue it it's
going to happen but
you can lay it all down and follow me
and when i surrendered like you did
that's when you know it took some time
but now i'm here getting to make
t-shirts that glorify god
getting to make videos that expose
darkness and glorify god you know all
the things that i
all the talents that god gave me i was
using for the world and he gave me an
opportunity to use it for him
and also um
i would just see repeatedly i can't
pinpoint like one particular time but
i've seen over and over and over how
when i was stressed about how's this
going to get paid for or i'm stressed
about like what's going to happen
god would always show up at the last
minute the day that bill needed to be
paid somebody's like i feel like to give
you this money or whatever and i would
just see that over and over and over
until i'm finally at the point where i
don't stress anymore like when i get to
that point i know god i know you got
something lord i know it's going to be
at the last minute i've almost seen like
this is how you always work i know it's
going to be last minute you know
so it gives you that peace of mind it's
about trust you have to
trust you know
i know you got a plan for me lord i know
you're going to come through so you
don't have to stress you know and that
verse that you shared keith which one
was it that proverbs 3 5 and 6. god will
direct your paths
yeah i mean to me that's that's that's
why that works out you know what i mean
god promises that if we give him the
driver's seat of our life then then he's
going to to steer the vehicle wherever
it needs to go and you know it's just
that letting go of the steering wheel is
the hard part for us
yeah so i guess i guess for me before i
before i share i'll bring up another
verse it's from
isaiah
55 i think six and seven
if i remember right
it says seek the lord while he may be
found call upon him while he is near let
the wicked forsake his way and the
unrighteous man his thoughts
let him return to the lord and he will
have mercy on him amen
the implication of that verse is there's
a point in your life
you may not be able to find god
right if you can't find god you can't
trust god
right so god gives us this window of
opportunity
to find him
and trust him
and if we
find ourselves and i'm not saying that
you know you can never call out to god
i'm saying there's there's it's like a
progression in life you can keep
rejecting keep rejecting keep rejecting
and god backs off and says okay
you know and and for all of us that's
that's that's different it could be for
some of us it's at our death right yeah
you can no longer see god at that at
that moment some people it's
they're they're rejecting and they and
they find god right before their death
you know
it's different times and different
circumstances for everybody but the
verse doesn't imply you know seek the
lord while he may be found because there
may be a time in your life where he may
not be able to be found by you you know
through whatever circumstances present
rejecting the holy spirit yeah rejecting
the holy spirit that's the idea
i guess for me
um it as i'm thinking about it i'm
thinking about another verse and i don't
remember where it's
at exactly but it it says um
uh hold on it just flew out of my head
oh man
can't think of it maybe it'll come to me
okay um oh
before you call i will answer
right and so in my life i think it's
always been a little bit of
before you call i will answer you can
see the hand of god leading
before you even asked or reached out to
him and that's really the story of the
gospel is like we think we're pursuing
god right and god all the while was the
one pursuing us and it's like hey god i
found you he's like no no really like
i you know i knew where you were at the
whole time and i'm the one that found
you
um
so for me it's kind of i would say it's
kind of weird it's almost always
manifested itself in financial ways the
trust part
so
i remember when my family left the
church i would
every once in a while pick up a bible
try to read it like this is not exciting
doesn't make any sense i don't know what
i'm reading
what do you do you put it away because
it's like i don't you know don't get it
so you know i just get absorbed in
entertainment
and
when i did start coming around and and
seeking god
you know
it's like you just
have god you know
you know put your money where your mouth
is it's like if you're telling me that
when i invest into you
that i'm gonna be blessed by it
okay let's test that out i mean because
yeah you can trust somebody but you
almost never trust anybody for no reason
yeah right you invest
or you test
in order to gain that trust right
even like with your kids like why do
they trust you well when they're like a
little toddler barely walking around
they know that you got them to be able
to catch them they know they can trust
you and they know that like man you know
i eat because mom and dad have always
provided for me and i have clothes and
they have you've provided all these
things and it's the same with god
god is not asking us to just blindly
trust him he's saying no no
try me out test me
and so that for my life i guess that was
one of the big ways is i it was it was
money it even started out that way with
call with college i went to school with
nothing and no plan
and i had i had
i graduated high school i thought i'm
not going to college
and my parents found out and they're
like no you're going to college and i'm
like well i don't have any money
and they're like well you're going to
figure it out it's like i didn't have a
job i had no money i had no savings i
had nothing i didn't even
i had decent grades but i didn't test as
well as my peers and so when i went
it was like well what am i going to do
so i took a year off between college and
and high school
and i thought well i guess i can brush
up on some of my studies and try to
improve and where i fell short
so i retook a standardized test
improved my score
and then you know i showed up on
orientation day like
clueless like i'm here okay like what am
i doing
split you off into different rooms and
they they put me in a room and
they're asking me to like fill out
classes and what i want to major in it's
like i don't i don't know
i don't even know why i'm here you know
this is like
what am i doing
i don't know the answers to all these
questions i feel like i've just been
tossed to the lions and
one of the people there found out later
as a professor
and he was helping you know people fill
out their class schedules and and try to
get advisement and all that
he asked me he's like i guess i must
have
displayed that i was clueless he's like
do you even know why you're here like
why are you in this room i was like no
i know
he's like well this is the this is the
honor students
and um
he's like let me take a look at your
grades and your your test scores and all
that
he's like oh yeah he's like we can put
you on a full ride scholarship
and so i started out in school on a full
ride scholarship
and that to me was like god
providing before before i even sought
him because at that point i wasn't even
seeking god i was just i'm going to
school my parents told me to go to
school i wasn't going to church anywhere
wasn't reading my bible none of that
and god is like providing you
before i even had an opportunity or
before i even took the opportunity to
seek him and so i didn't stay on the
four-wire scholarship i actually was
later on a terrible student and
that's a whole nother story
but
when i did encounter god you know i
started tithing when i started making
money and all this and god always came
through always came through always came
through and it's the same today and now
i'm in that same position you talked
about i used to worry about a lot of
stuff financially now it's just like
i wonder whatever how many god's got it
i wonder how many people that actually
happens to that don't take that next
step you know what i mean like god's
literally hooking them up yeah they
don't realize where it's coming from and
god's preparing the way for them to make
a decision for him and they deny him
yeah i think at the end of life you will
only begin to understand at what lengths
god did go to to save every single one
of us you know those scenes yeah all of
us probably have these stories whether
you believe in god or not it's like
god is working behind the scenes to win
your heart and he's and he's and he's
opening doors and having things happen
and sometimes i mean it works on the
other side of the fence too god is
allowing us to be broken there's people
that need to be broken it's weird you
think it's a chain of circumstances like
you're talking about like for me
you know it it meant that i wound up in
different kinds of classes than the
general college populace i got to be in
smaller classes with my quote unquote
peers which is interesting because i i
sat in one class on health and most of
the people when they were asked by the
professor was an md
about depression most of these people
that were honor students raised their
hands that they were like
were or had been really depressed
i'm like okay wait a minute
these are the people that are supposed
to be like your doctors your lawyers
they're getting the best shot
and they they apparently don't have it
all together and that was really
eye-opening to me and i was
to be honest i was depressed too i mean
i could identify but you think you're
the only one but you think of the little
steps like i remember this one guy i met
i still keep in in contact with him
today you have guinea hundradenko he's
from belarus and he invited me
to some
on-campus christian meetings
i wasn't going to church anywhere and i
was like man i really miss that you know
i would like to and it was like free
pizza and you know the whole thing i'm
like yeah i'll do free pizza and listen
to somebody talk to you but once a week
so i would go
and
you know you
it's like you meet one person you start
you meet another you start doing things
and it's just like one step after
another step after another step
and then later on i met some other
people and then that's the church i
wound up going to and it's just like one
step after another leading
leading and guiding you still keep up
with this guy that he's a chemical
engineer for bp
see you can have a pizza ministry too
yeah that's right i could save people
with pizza i was thinking about what
you're saying like you know there's all
these times that god's trying to get
your attention or or allowing you to be
broken down and stuff i have a lot of
discussions and debates or whatever i
call them with atheists and stuff and
that's the stuff i i bring up too i'm
like
god is trying to get your attention
these things like there might be some
atheists that like oh i survived a car
crash you know it must be karma or
whatever you know they're they're
putting the credit somewhere else it's
like god is like trying to get your
attention
uh you were mentioning like
that that time it's almost like a window
of opportunity with god you know
and like you said for some people it
might be longer
i feel like i had that time period too
because
god revealed himself to me in a very
personal way just like you it was like
this school thing for you
for me it was about a certain job that i
wanted that you couldn't get unless you
knew somebody and god kept
guiding my path and put me
working for a person who was best
friends with the manager of that place
[Music]
and i gave god the credit you know and i
realized it was him
and then i was like at a point where i
was like but i'm not ready to surrender
i was still gonna do my life i was just
adding
my belief in god to my life but it
wasn't like i invited him in
and i remember one night
by myself where it just felt like god
was saying
why don't you pray and during that
prayer because i
submitted to that call why don't you
pray and i just prayed for generic
things in life
and uh that was when it was like god was
saying this is your moment
and i
i got scared you know i was like no that
can't be
but right then it was like this reality
check of
you were seeking for me and i'm showing
myself to you this is your moment
[Music]
you're running away at this point it was
like a reality check of you are
you are running away and if i you know i
don't know if god would have pursued me
after that but i felt like this is now
or never like i gotta do i gotta
surrender here i've heard a lot of
people say that in in different
testimonies like they recognize there's
a moment like if i didn't choose to
follow god then i never would have yeah
and i would turn away
yeah that's why i'm very passionate
about testimonies
thank you so much for sharing you guys
and i'm sure you guys going to be asking
what about you
so i just want to share with you guys
there are many in my life right i mean
i'm sure if i actually like hey how many
times you know it was the moment
you were trusting god there's many right
thanks so much for sharing uh i just
want to share a little bit of my
testimony you can say i grew up in a
christian home
and you know growing up going to church
with your parents and stuff like that
and you know when i was like
12 13
you know those kind of ages kind of like
you know i can handle myself you know
like they give you a little more freedom
and
so in the age of you know 13 14
hang out with the wrong people
friends from the church and i'm not
saying you know whatever but you know
sometimes you know
you know there are some people in the
church that use friends that you call
friends
i mean they're not christian you know i
mean maybe they don't have a
relationship with god
so you know i started you know you know
you know
doing bad things you know smoking
drinking whatever you know i'm from
mexico so you don't have uh you need to
have an id
to get alcohol and all the stuff so it's
like you go store i want this you pay
and leave
so
in that time since 13
14 to 18
17 and a half i mean that was like five
years of
no walking with the lord
but i was going to church because you
know mom and dad
take me to church
but i go there and go pray because
whatever i want to start in my bible
whatever you know they buy me books and
stuff like that i read it
aside you know things like that
but um
music and parties and blah blah right
but let me tell you
i know my parents they were praying my
mommy was praying they see this child
dressing all black you know i was into
about uh heavy metal rock and you know
rap and all stuff and that's you know in
the 90s
but let me tell you
believe it or not
i used to paint my hair you know
green red blue and all the stuff that i
always cover with the hat
you know in back 10 years you can wear
your hat to go to school high school and
stuff like that and should we check now
yeah yeah that's right
because i don't have hair anymore
i was i was very into about myself you
know my look and my hair and painting
and
you know the cool looking on the you
know has to be the new music and i was
me
and the thing is that
my brother my mirror brother always in
the church my older brother you know
it's my kind of my personality maybe
more than that
but uh you know he left the church now
he's back the guy in the middle
uh my brother carlos
uh he never left the church uh you know
he was the guy in the uh uh
uh
how do you say one of the the offerings
the oh yeah like a deacon a deacon you
know he became deacon early age and like
all in the church seriously like his
personality
not like me i mean i'm not i'm not he's
dry but you know he's like more
confident and
you know serious and talk you know make
a joke some of that i don't know it's
annoying
another guy and he you know he preached
i mean he never went to be a pastor or
anything but he can give you a revival
seminar like amazing
and so the whole point is that he
i mean he sees his little brother
like
no way no like no rules in my house like
in my life not only my house in my in my
life and let me tell you when i was
going to hang out with my friends and i
knew they're going to be doing
not good stuff
i have to pass
the area where the books are and i knew
it was bibles there i knew it was
christian books and stuff like that and
it was something in me
that
what is right you know what i'm saying
like you know that's right and i don't
want to look at it i just want to go
through it and every time when i was
just hanging out with my friends or go
to a party or something i knew
that i need to go past that
to where the books are
and i feel something like hey
you know you're going to be doing
something like the books
yeah that's right so i was like oh god
you know i was like i just want to leave
you know and i remember my brother
carlos
saw me one time and he and i was like
that added to like i don't have time for
you man i mean to me and that time i
didn't have no feelings yeah i don't
care about what you think about me i
just gotta tell you everything i mean i
just that kind of added to you and my my
brother told me hey
can you give me
one hour of the 24 hours that god gave
you
mom just give me one hour
and i was like hurry up man because my
body's gonna pick me up you know kind of
like so dry
so he sit down and he told me
i don't know if it was the last chapter
but at the last chapters of revelation
when the city of jerusalem is going to
come down and they're all
redeemers
they're going to be inside but the
people that reject christ they're going
to be outside the city
and he told me to say hey
the castillejo's family is going to be
inside the city
i don't want to see my brother to be
outside the city
please think about what are you doing in
life wow and i was like i never had that
like nobody told me that you know i
never heard that and
all those years going to church i never
heard that preaching before wasn't that
personal like that yeah it was like
straight to your heart yeah it's just
bam and i think i believe god knew how
to talk yeah you know because i was like
i don't know i mean i know i've been
here for like five months you know and i
always say like hey we need to punch the
wall
break that the eyes because i had that
thing that
he went to punch you know the holy
spirit is like boom do it right
and
and i was like
he would show me you know of course you
know verse in the bible stuff like that
and let me tell you
maybe that day that exactly moment i
didn't give my life to christ
but the seat of the holy spirit was
there
he was touching and and i left you know
like okay thanks so much you got one
hour i'm out you know
but let me tell you i don't know when
exactly since that moment to this i
don't know exactly
but it was kind of close six months four
months i don't know
and i was dressing like you know black
heavy metal and black beans and
three four guys walking with my friends
in the street people just moved to the
other side because we were just
whatever bad news bad news
but the beautiful thing about the gospel
let me tell you that mercy and something
like
that he forgive your sense i mean tense
god you know like put it over there you
know the deeper the sea man don't take
it out again
so to me is that i remember
i was i don't know if i'm sure it was a
party or something but i was outside
and hang out with my friends i was
sitting down and
you know i'm just
hanging out with my friends right
outside
and it was a moment
and i believe i'm not kidding you
that the holy spirit was just like
you know just come in
into your mind
and i was just thinking i was like you
know drinking and doing this listen to
music and girls friends whatever
this is not my world
and i see this guy talking what he's
going to do with this girl and this day
you know the whole scene right my life
and we and i was thinking that moment
that
that's that's the maxima this is the the
crazy thing that you want to hang out
with friends and
money or whatever right
and he said this is not my work
and i knew that that saturday evening
there were good friends of mine growing
up from church
they were hanging out
doing hang out eating meals or talking
and like a healthy environment
and i was choosing
the good life
and seriously at that moment i was like
what i'm doing here
like what i'm doing here man
so
in that moment you know i left
and and i didn't want to hang out with
my friends
and people called me like hey are you
going to go to the quinceanera are you
going to go here you know call me i was
like you know back to anywhere on social
media so they have to call you so it's
like no i'm not gonna be here you know
i can't come on man just this night i
was like no i can't you know
and decided to stay home
but let me tell you it was the moment of
process of thinking uh like the bible
saying i said you know let's
come and let us reason again let's
reason together
let me tell you that's that's how the
lord does
he wants to use like hey let's sit down
let's talk about your life man i mean
you want to go through that that that
that or you want me to help you out
so
he was the moment that i was getting up
a fight in the morning
reading
like a devotional time uh no like a
bible study time my bible and my
knowledge of like a bible study
before go to high school my last year of
high school
that was like totally different even the
principal
of the uh my high school they come to me
that she's like
i don't know what you're doing
but whatever you're doing works keep it
up because two years ago i mean high
school in mexico is three years so the
first two two years i mean you were
crazy i don't know what you're doing
push my teacher like inside with the
belt i mean that was a joke
not me you know sam twelve you know all
the stuff but to me as they i was
getting up
studying my bible before i go to high
school
and i love it sometimes i i was late for
high school because i was reading my
bible wow and i was i was so excited so
in
uh in 1996
i was baptized
i was 18 years old wow and i didn't
baptize you know when i was 11 10 i know
some parents they're like and i'm not
saying you know that's fine
but uh my my daddy used to tell me
because you know uh the brothers you
know they uh many people from the church
is like hey you wanna do something about
that and my dad you said no
when he make his own decision you know
he's gonna study or witness study when
he's ready and i don't know if he's
right or wrong but that's how it was my
life i went through this chunk of the
time and not with god i was going to
church
but my mind is not there right you know
and so that was the the trust in god and
i'm sure you know
many many things in my life i can tell
you oh that was a moment that was the
moment the one specific thing
uh it was that moment that was like
what i'm doing here
you know and so we can trust god that's
what the the passion i have that you
know i mean what is you your story man
what is your story what's your story you
know share it you know how how powerful
god
it is
it can change people's life and can help
us in those crazy moments
in our life
so
my last question
is can we trust the lord
in these
end times events
now it's not in our lives what about in
this you hear this you hear that you're
that and
i believe you know reading the scripture
and all those beautiful passages that we
share
can we can we trust the lord in this
heavy times that we're going to
i think it's im
imperative that we trust in the lord i
don't think we're going to make it
through this craziness because it's just
really it's going to get crazier from
here on out
i mean that's that's what the bible says
right a time like no other time has ever
been since the creation of man like like
the end of the world will be a roller
coaster ride and i think that we are
called to just hold on to to to christ
with with all of our might
and trust that he has us in his best in
his best will and that he will protect
us and that he will guide us and and
also pray for your children like lord
you said that you would
save my children save my children and i
guarantee you your parents are praying
for you you know
and i know my parents were praying for
me i know mikey's parents you know years
i don't know where years we're at at
that time but you know prayer is is is
one of those things that just allows god
to have closer and closer access to us
at some point
i was gonna say the same thing like
i don't think we have a choice man we
got to trust in god in these times man
because
what what is your other option you know
if it gets to the point where it's like
you know
uh reject your god or die
are you willing to
reject god for a couple more years
on this messed up earth that's going to
be like you know tyrannical or whatever
like
this world has nothing to offer us that
is that compares with the gift that god
wants to give you eternal life and not
just eternal life but in a perfect place
you know
and and it's not worth
rejecting him over a couple more years
to extend to your natural life here in a
world that's not even
yeah great you know
you
do you remember that guy that we
interviewed that um
um is it daryl scott oh yeah that um
daughter was in the yeah his daughter
was in cold mine i mean i would just
hope and pray in whatever situation that
i get into like you go out like that do
you believe in god yes i do
you know and i hope you do too you know
i hope those are like like my last words
it's amazing i'm just gonna say
that trust is a process so
you know if you don't trust god now as
things get more difficult it's just
going to be that much harder in that
crazy trust that's right if you start
now well it's that's easier it'll be
much easier later and that that's that's
why you you start with little things and
god starts oftentimes with little things
you know it's like are you gonna trust
me with your money now for some people
it's like a real big thing you know like
who who do you trust with your money do
you just trust anybody right
so
um
you know that's that's one way you can
trust god with your um but there are
other ways you know
you got a sick kid you know you're
praying for your kid you're watching
them get better i'm not saying you don't
ever treat them but i'm saying that's
that's something you can
you know build trust on you got but even
if it doesn't go right you know what i
mean like like how do you build trust in
a time that that it doesn't go right
well i think you build it
um in times
where it's easier and things are going
well and then as you get to that time
period where things aren't going well
and you're trusting and you come out on
the other side restored you know or like
job
i mean he trusted god through that time
even though it was terrible
and on the other end what i mean
he had
everything that he had was multiplied
yeah you know
everything he had multiplied and and he
came out
better
so
yeah we just gotta we've got to trust
but it's so much easier to do it now
than later otherwise it's going to be
and it's going to really rock you if you
if you get to that point things are
really challenging
what do you do
so start now
okay so uh before we ended this this
show i just want to share with you the
last scripture
is psalms 40
verse 4 it said blessed is the man who
puts
his trust in the lord
so i know you guys watching this video
and i hope it was encouragement and that
the times the crazy times that we're
living uh put your trust in god and let
me tell you uh god's gonna be there
jesus is gonna be just waiting please uh
open that door
and ask jesus to come into your heart
thank you so much and that was led live
here in little live studios thanks so
much for your support here and patreon
like our videos share this link so other
people can be blessed thanks so much and
we'll see you
next time
[Music]
you